eskimos le nom de la plateforme en ligne
du plan climat air énergie territorial
de saint quentin en yvelines un outil
virtuel destiné à tous les acteurs du
territoire pour permettre
l'accompagnement de la mise en oeuvre du
programme
les gens vont voir suivre de manière la
plus précise possible les évolutions de
consommation
ils vont pouvoir suivre aussi la mise en
application du plan climat air énergie
est également ils vont pouvoir proposer
des nouvelles actions
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
va contribuer à cette plateforme dans le
traitement des données notamment de la
consommation énergétique
c'est beaucoup plus facile de demander à
un certain un certain nombre de
personnes 2
de suivre leur consommation de dévaluer
leur consommation au quotidien à travers
un cadre un cadre d'évaluation qui
fournira avec une mini formation que
nous même d'aller chercher la donne est
donc ça ça responsabilise les gens par
rapport à leur consommation et puis ça
permet pour nous de recueillir de la
donnée fiable au quotidien faire émerger
une filière transition énergétique sur
le territoire ou encore valoriser les
commerces en circuit court
plusieurs actions du plan climat air
énergie territorial lancé ce mardi 11
décembre et voté le 20 septembre dernier
d'adapter le territoire aux changements
climatiques en essayant de à la fois
réduire les consommations d'énergie et
d'utiliser au maximum des énergies
renouvelables pour nous rendre le plus
indépendant possible par rapport aux
énergies fossiles et au nucléaire on a
des gros progrès à faire par rapport à
l'isolation thermique et là il va
falloir à travailler sur des rénovations
énergétiques de l'ensemble des bâtiments
depuis juin 2016 la plateforme repères
habitat permet aux saint quentinois
d'engager les démarches pour une
rénovation énergétique